we have a fox news alert the desperate
search for answers continue in the case
for the missing 22 year old gabby petito
we have new video of several police
officers currently at the home of her
fiance
person of interest brian laundry fox
news carly schimpkins is at the scene
and she joins us live in florida with
the latest carly what do you know it's a
scene behind you lawrence yes there is a
lot of movement happening right now
because a police officer just walked out
of the laundry family house we do know
why the police officers are inside they
posted a tweet saying that they are
talking to the family at the family's
request they are not talking to brian
they also say that more information is
to come on that front police arrived at
the house
a little over an hour ago three police
officers walked in in quick succession
no knock on the door they just walked
right in which means which suggests that
the family knew that they were coming
another police officer arrived about 15
minutes ago he was carrying
a brown paper bag it was empty i can't
confirm what that bag was it could
possibly be an evidence bag but like i
said i couldn't get a significant enough
look at the bag to tell you with
certainty what it was speaking of
significance this is the most
significant movement in the case so far
i was here this morning yesterday
morning the house was completely dark
the the biggest thing that happened this
morning was that somebody turned on a
light which proved that people were
inside the house some people started to
wonder if the family was inside because
people hadn't seen them for a while the
first time police came to the laundry
family house was on september 11th when
gabby's mom
filed the missing persons report and
police were met basically with nothing
mom and dad came to the door brian's
parents came to the door handed them a
piece of paper that basically said talk
to our lawyers and that's who the police
have been basically communicating with
ever since brian has not spoken out
there is another significant development
that broke about an hour ago as well
grand county utah police said that there
is no link between the disappearance of
gabby petito and the double homicide
that took place of that newlywed couple
both in moab utah if you recall there
was a
police police came to moab
and spoke to gabby and brian on august
12th because um somebody called them
because of a of a disturbance that took
place turned out they had gotten into a
physical altercation but no criminal
charges were filed
police have greatly stressed so far
throughout this week that brian while he
is a person of interest
they can't prove any criminality thus
far and he has his right to remain
silent that right to remain silent has
angered many people because many here
today protesters included believe that
he knows something significant about
gabby and could have been the last
person to see her lawrence yeah carl
definitely planned a semantics game to
cover their tale as well uh while the
investigation plays i heard that there's
a protest as well out there carly so
i'll be checking in with you throughout
the night to see
if you have anything to report new
thanks so much carla hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else